[Música]
mal contados más o menos ya han pasado
seis meses desde el inicio del gobierno
del presidente Gustavo Petro en Colombia
El mandatario ha impulsado varias y
profundas reformas a nivel tributario de
salud laboral y también pensional
algunas de ellas Todavía están a la
espera de ser propuestas y de ser
presentadas tanto a el legislativo como
a la sociedad colombiana las propuestas
como es de esperarse pues han generado
diferente tipo de opiniones en una
sociedad que ya de por sí es una
sociedad profundamente polarizada
recientemente las calles de diferentes
ciudades colombianas fueron escenario de
manifestaciones tanto a favor como en
contra de dichas reformas puntualmente
estamos hablando de la Reforma al
sistema de salud que fueron las
manifestaciones que tuvieron lugar la
semana pasada en diferentes ciudades del
país el mandatario también ha impulsado
una renovada relación con Venezuela a
nivel internacional y una mesa de
diálogo en México con la guerrilla del
eln por eso hoy en el debate 24 ponemos
la lupa en Colombia y analizamos las
recientes manifestaciones y nos
preguntamos cómo está este país después
de haber recibido en la casa de nariño a
Gustavo Petro hace Ya seis meses pues
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Isabel Cristina Zuleta ella es líder
social y ambiental es senadora por el
pacto histórico y también está con
nosotros en el estudio de France 24 Ciro
Alejandro Ramírez senador por el partido
centro democrático a los dos les doy la
bienvenida al programa Gracias por estar
con nosotros y le recuerdo que ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de esta discusión de este debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios las
preguntas todo lo que ustedes deseen
consultar o comentar a través de las
redes sociales nos encuentran en Twitter
en Facebook y en instagram también nos
encuentran allí como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
y a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arroba santilogo no olviden también ya
para terminar que todos los contenidos
de este programa también están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas de
podcast Apple podcast en Spotify en
deezer y en TuneIn
pues comenzamos Entonces el programa le
doy la bienvenida entonces a la senadora
Zuleta Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en el debate de France 24 y
comienzo preguntándole qué balance hace
usted de estos primeros seis meses de
gobierno de Gustavo Petro en Colombia
continúa esta luna de miel que hay entre
normalmente entre los presidentes recién
llegados y las sociedades o cómo está
Colombia en este momento
bueno no Nosotros estamos muy contentos
en los territorios por primera vez vemos
Un gobierno arrojado a los territorios
los diálogos vinculantes y además las
audiencias que hemos hecho desde el
pacto histórico y desde nuestra bancada
Como cada una de las ministras y
ministros ha estado recorriendo el país
para nosotros desde los territorios ha
sido un balance muy positivo por primera
vez nos sentimos escuchados Y eso lo
hablo como movimiento social y como
movimiento ambiental cada vez que se ha
requerido la presencia de un alto
funcionario en el territorio allí lo
hemos tenido eso no lo veíamos antes
tampoco veíamos que hubiese una apertura
para discutir temas complejos temas
difíciles que queríamos discutir desde
los territorios por ejemplo los los
temas que hoy son reforma han sido
luchas históricas para nosotros ha sido
una lucha histórica la posibilidad de
reformar el código minero hemos estado
en una serie de audiencias por todo el
país también la reforma la salud ha
parte de una lucha histórica las
reformas al cine al Sistema Nacional
ambiental lo que tiene que ver con
nuestras lagunas con nuestros ríos allí
hemos estado visitando con las ministras
los territorios Y eso para nosotros nos
da un balance muy positivo nos sentimos
escuchados creo que el plan Nacional de
desarrollo recoge gran parte de lo que
fue esa participación y por este lado le
doy la bienvenida también al senador
Ramírez Gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa y la misma pregunta como
Punto de partida qué balance hace usted
de estos seis meses de gobierno Petro Un
gobierno de izquierda el primero en la
historia de Colombia Santiago los saludo
a mi compañera del Congreso a los
televidentes yo veo en estos meses una
radiografía de un país hoy preocupado
con una gran incertidumbre en nuestra
economía eso lo ha reflejado las calles
en los últimos días nosotros lo que
queremos es de manera mezquina que al
gobierno le vaya bien porque si al
gobierno le va bien al país le va bien
como en cualquier país pero lo que ha
presentado este presidente en los
los próximos días semanas es reformas
para estatizar para darle más
competencias funciones al Estado
colombiano y yo creo que eso va en
contravía de lo que ha demostrado las
experiencias en los países más
desarrollados lo que nosotros defendemos
es un estado austero pequeño pero aquí
quieren volver a que el estado haga todo
y esa es la gran preocupación de los
colombianos Hoy vemos una gran
incertidumbre en materia de inversión y
sobre todo en un año que las
proyecciones no son buenas en
crecimiento económico en medio de la
región de latinoamérica pues Colombia
hoy está no en los primeros lugares como
lo estuvo en los últimos años sino ya
por debajo de la mitad de la tabla y lo
que nos preocupa de todo esto es que
pues se ha demostrado Porque esa
preocupación de los colombianos pues
está reflejado en las encuestas donde la
imagen del presidente de la república
cae estrepitosamente Sí usted habla de
estatizar y la senadora
Zuleta habla de luchas históricas aquí
como hacer balance continuó para hacer
la ronda la inversa senadora Zuleta Cómo
hacer ese balance de lo que usted habla
de estatizar pero que no se
malinterprete el término con un proyecto
o un intento de garantizar esa presencia
de estado que tal vez es una de las
grandes deudas pendientes que ha tenido
el gobierno colombiano a lo largo de la
historia no solo de este gobierno sino a
lo largo de la historia esa es nuestra
diferencia yo no veo que el estado sea
más eficiente para prestar los servicios
que debe prestar el estado A veces de
manera mixta o privada se prestan de
manera más eficiente en el caso de una
gran reforma que ha presentado en los
últimos días al congreso de Colombia es
la reforma a la salud donde hoy tenemos
un sistema mixto y lo quiere estatizar
devolvernos 30 años como funcionaba
Colombia donde la cobertura era menos
del 50% y hoy tenemos una cobertura casi
universal hablando de
hidrocarburos del petróleo se ha
demostrado una voluntad negativa y en
contra del sector extractivo en Colombia
también por hablar que el estado haga
más
habla de un sistema pensional donde el
estado va a recuperar casi todos los
fondos en cabeza de una entidad que es
del estado y así podemos mencionarles
casi todos los sectores donde quiere
darle más competencias al estado y yo no
sé en dónde pero creo que la historia
económica del mundo ha demostrado que el
estado no es más eficiente para prestar
ciertos servicios y yo creo que el
estado debe presentarse al mercado
solamente para corregir unas fallas
mientras el estado sea más pequeño creo
que es más eficiente la sociedad al
momento que el estado preste ciertos
servicios senadora Zuleta vamos por
partes porque aquí hay varios temas
sobre la mesa quiero hablar de esas
luchas históricas que van en línea con
lo que menciona el el senador Ramírez
algunos puntos que se tienen que mejorar
de la presencia del estado en diferentes
regiones eso pues el estado tiene que
ser en algunos casos el que impulse ese
tipo de iniciativas cuáles son esas
luchas históricas esas deudas pendientes
que tal vez no van conectadas con este
proceso de presencia de estado o
enfatizar e impulsar algunos proyectos
bueno todos definitivamente estamos
reclamando la presencia del estado en
las regiones en muchas regiones de
Colombia El único estado que hemos
tenido Lamentablemente ha sido la
presencia de las fuerzas militares y esa
presencia de las fuerzas militares es
muy importante pero no es capaz de
cubrir metro a metro cuadrado en nuestro
país se necesita una fortaleza
institucional para superar las
violencias entonces parte de la lucha
histórica es la lucha por la paz esa
lucha por la paz que requiere un buen
servicio de salud Porque si bien Se ha
mejorado en términos de
posibilidades de Acceder al servicio de
salud No se está cubriendo hoy esas
necesidades en los lugares más alejados
de nuestro país en muchos lugares no
tenemos ni siquiera centros de salud han
tenido que salir esos centros de salud
se han venido quebrando los hospitales
se han venido quebrando las mismas eps y
esos intermediarios de salud lo que
nosotros estamos diciendo es que se
pueda atender el derecho salud y porque
ha sido una lucha histórica precisamente
porque hemos tenido que acudir no solo a
las calles sino a los organismos de
justicia y a la posibilidad de la tutela
el mayor número de tutelas en nuestro
país se da para acceder a los servicios
de salud si es un derecho conexo a la
vida nosotros no tenemos tiempo que
esperar y muchas personas han muerto lo
que le llamamos aquí en Colombia en el
Paseo de la muerte y otra lucha
histórica que es muy importante que
tiene que llegar a los territorios y que
para nosotros es trascendental para
superar esos niveles de violencia es la
desigualdad Colombia es el segundo país
más desigual de 18 de la octe de nuestra
América y ese segundo país más desigual
lo que quiere decir es que tenemos unos
niveles de pobreza enormes nosotros
tenemos que superar esos niveles de
pobreza y en ese proyecto de salud
estamos hablando de los determinantes
sociales y ambientales que tienen que
ver con los niveles de Progreso Entonces
nosotros estamos juntando luchas
históricas para tener un mejor acceso no
solo en las ciudades sino en los lugares
más alejados aquí estamos diciendo aquí
hay buenas clínicas en Bogotá y buenas
clínicas en Medellín hay excelentes
clínicas pero no en los municipios del
bajo cauca no tenemos clínicas a donde
acceder la gente tiene que recorrer por
carreteras completamente destruidas que
hoy no tenemos buenos servicios
precisamente para horas y horas de
camino llegar y buscar en ese paseo de
la muerte que sean atendidas y en el
tema del petróleo a mí me gusta llamar
la atención sobre el hecho de que es una
empresa nuestra es una empresa así
estatizada estatizada y que retomó el
control el estado colombiano por la
fuerza popular la fuerza que hizo un
sindicato que se llama la uso la uso
logra que sea Nuestra Empresa la empresa
de todos los colombianos justamente la
reforma la salud es la que ha llevado a
las calles a cientos de colombianos lo
veíamos en imágenes la semana pasada en
diferentes puntos de Colombia en
principalmente en el centro de Bogotá la
capital colombiana solo para un breve
resumen de lo que tiene esta o la que
contiene esta reforma la salud cinco
puntos importantes es un principio de
universalidad un sistema preventivo y
predictivo tres recursos para garantizar
la sostenibilidad del mismo sistema como
tal dignificar a los trabajadores del
sector de la salud esto a raíz de lo que
sucedió con la pandemia Kobe 19 donde
los trabajadores de salud pues tuvieron
que hacer jornadas larguísimas para
poder atender la emergencia de la
pandemia no es una realidad solo de
Colombia es algo que se vio en los
diferentes sistemas de salud en los
diferentes países del mundo y también el
acompañamiento técnico son en breves
palabras lo que alberga esta reforma al
sistema de salud por qué genera tanta
polarización porque profundiza estas
divisiones esta reforma a la salud hay
falta de comunicación por parte del
gobierno para dar a entender estos
puntos qué es lo que falla en esta
reforma desde el punto de vista de su
bancada Santiago nos quieren un sistema
de salud ideologizado y creo que ha
demostrado Colombia tener uno de los
mejores sistemas de salud comparados con
nuestra región hablemos de Suramérica y
Centroamérica nosotros hoy podemos decir
que gracias a nuestro sistema de salud
que es un sistema mixto un sistema
solidario donde el que tiene paga y
subsidia al que no tiene donde hoy en un
hospital la persona que tiene y que no
tiene es atendida y tiene el acceso a
los mismos servicios y mismos
medicamentos sistema contributivo y
sistema subsidiado son los dos sistemas
que hay y nos quieren acabar el sistema
de seguro que funciona en Colombia para
que el estado sea el Que responda por
todo Ahí es donde nosotros decimos si
nosotros estatizamos todos tenemos hoy
que pedirle al Estado que solucione
alcaldes gobernadores consejos y fondos
evidentemente públicos donde va a
resolver todo hoy nosotros tenemos una
demostración que gracias a ese sistema
de salud donde la inversión privada
tenía el 72% de las unidades de cuidados
intensivo en Colombia y fue uno de los
pocos países que resistió la embestida
de la pandemia vemos el caso de Ecuador
vemos el caso de Perú el caso de chile
Argentina Italia Estados Unidos donde se
sus temas colapsaron el de Colombia hoy
con verificación de la organización
Panamericana de la salud de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud dieron
reconocimiento a Colombia por nuestro
sistema y como tuvo la capacidad de
atender esa pandemia lo que quieren es
Borrar todo y lo que funciona acabarlo
hacer un borrón y cuenta nueva para
poder solucionar lo que hoy funciona mal
Los profesionales de la salud necesitan
mejores condiciones Cómo podemos mejorar
el acceso a la Colombia rural dispersa
que es donde lo que dice la senadora
podemos mejorar la atención Cómo podemos
hacer más rápido la atención de ciertos
especialistas en materia de salud Pero
no por eso para arreglar eso tenemos que
destruir todo lo que hay Porque llevamos
30 años en prueba y error mejorando un
sistema que se ha construido desde todas
las ideologías izquierda derecha todos
los presidentes han puesto su granito de
arena para mejorar lo que hay y este
gobierno lo que quiere hacer es destruir
todo lo que hay y comenzar de cero por
este lado senadora su opinión bueno
nosotros vemos con gran alegría cuando
se radica el proyecto de ley que por fin
se recogen las diferentes perspectivas
de la salud No habíamos tenido ninguna
posibilidad en gobiernos anteriores
ninguna los movimientos de salud y en
Medellín Tenemos uno que todos los
miércoles está en el parque berrío
reclamando una sola cosa y es que nos
atiendan de forma oportuna la atención
oportuna es tan importante como el tener
la posibilidad del acceso a la salud
porque no De nada te sirve que tengas un
carnet que puedas estar inscrito y que
te puedan atender y que efectivamente
haya como si se demoran un año en darte
una cita de nada te sirve la
tramitología de estar de un lado para
otro si lo que va a suceder es que
puedas quedar ciego que puedas quedar
sordo porque el tiempo en materia de
salud es una cosa sumamente importante
hoy tenemos un problema gravísimo y es
que no se atiende a la gente con
oportunidad y el otro es que
efectivamente como lo decía el senador
el personal de salud está pésimamente
remunerado no hay respeto a los derechos
laborales los sindicatos más importantes
no son ni siquiera de los médicos son de
los enfermeros y eran las enfermeras el
personal de salud tiene una crisis y
efectivamente si no te pagan si no te
tratan bien si no te permiten
sindicalizarse y si no te permiten que
exijas tus derechos por ejemplo en el
chocó se demoraron 12 meses habían
funcionarios de salud del sistema de
salud que no le habían pagado en 12
meses con Qué ganas van a atender la
situación tan aterradora que vivimos de
contaminación hídrica la situación que
se vive en el choco de violencia si no
les han pagado Entonces no solo no hay
medicamentos o sea lo de la acetaminofén
en Colombia No es un chiste es real y lo
único que te permiten que le permiten a
ese médico que se demoró estudiando diez
años seis años más las especializaciones
la subespecializaciones es que formular
una acetaminofén ni siquiera hay
libertad para ese ejercicio
como Colombia donde la educación está
prácticamente privatizada para poder
acceder a buena educación de calidad
también es sumamente costosa debo
avanzar con otros de los temas que tengo
para la agenda del programa el tema de
salud sigue siendo una coyuntura y está
abierta en Colombia en este momento el
debate está a todo nivel abierto en ese
país pero debo preguntarle por algunos
de los temas a nivel internacional de
cómo se está manejando la relación
internacional de el presidente Petro y
aquí hay dos puntos muy importantes uno
la relación con Venezuela senador que es
una gran apuesta que está haciendo
Colombia también le ha permitido a
Venezuela ganar algo de visibilidad
nuevamente a Nicolás Maduro a nivel
internacional a raíz de estos acuerdos a
nivel comercial el restablecimiento de
los vuelos entre Venezuela y Colombia y
otro punto importante es la relación con
Perú en donde Petro ya fue declarado
persona no grata por el congreso de ese
país qué decir del relacionamiento que
ha tenido el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
en estos seis meses con la región yo le
agrego un país más Guatemala donde un
enfrentamiento público en que el
presidente llama teila y dice
guerrillero al presidente de colombiano
diciéndole que no respeta las
instituciones en ese país eso uno dos
nuestro presidente el de Colombia hoy es
reconocido como persona no grata por el
congreso de Perú Pues cómo no le van a
decir eso sí el presidente Gustavo Petro
el de Colombia le dice a los peruanos
que solo son unos nazis por marchar o
porque están en contra de las marchas o
por lo que fuera un presidente no se
puede referir así hacia los habitantes
de un vecino país pero sí muy mejor
amigo de Venezuela donde vemos una
dictadura y un régimen que ha sido voz
populi para toda la región que ha
facilitado
el ejercicio de los grupos criminales
que hoy operan en Colombia y se refugian
en ese país dos que también ha todas
esas operaciones de narcotráfico gracias
a esas organizaciones criminales y mucho
se habla de ese cartel de Los Soles que
Son miembros de la fuerza pública de
Venezuela ahí si no pasa absolutamente
nada y lo que nosotros vemos es que es
visibiliza nombrándolo como bebedor como
país
recipiente Pues de esas negociaciones
con el eln entonces lo que nosotros
vemos es que unas políticas de
relaciones exteriores de este país
totalmente un fracaso cuando lo
reconocen como no grata agarrándose con
el presidente de Guatemala pero sí mejor
amigo de un presidente más bien de una
dictador que ha facilitado la operación
del narcotráfico y de organizaciones
criminales que operan en Colombia
senadora no se está jugando aquí mucho
la imagen internacional de Colombia en
este relacionamiento con el gobierno de
Venezuela siendo un tema tan sensible en
la comunidad internacional aunque
también hay que entender la importancia
por lo menos en términos comerciales son
países vecinos históricos
que tiene un intercambio comercial
fronterizo millonario y es la gran
apuesta no activar la economía a través
de esa inversión que puede llegar de
Colombia para reactivar la economía
venezolana le puede funcionar muy bien
al empresariado pero pero aquí no hay
mucha presión en el tema internacional
dándole tanto apoyo a Venezuela Bueno yo
acabo de venir de arauca dice una gira
por la frontera es la frontera más
importante en nuestro país realmente de
ella depende la orinoquía depende en
nuestros ríos fronterizos tenemos una
situación ambiental que resolver eso no
se va a poder hacer si no tenemos una
relación con el país vecino No hay
manera de resolver los problemas de
degradación ambiental fronterizos y esos
ríos que dependen de los dos países si
no tenemos una buena relación como
ambientalista tengo que decir es
necesaria esa relación el río no da
espera las fronteras son vivas no solo
por los asuntos comerciales que son de
suma importancia la gente está feliz o
sea solo el poder pasar solo el poder
intercambiar como familias y hay que
recordar que en esas fronteras vivas
tenemos la misma familia donde los
primos Los Hermanos están del otro lado
romper relaciones familiares más allá de
los asuntos ideológicos y es un daño
enorme recuperar esas relaciones
familiares recuperar las relaciones
comerciales y para nosotros los
ambientalistas la posibilidad de hablar
de esas fronteras vivas de esas selvas
de esos ríos que dependen de la relación
entre los dos países es de suma
importancia Pero además hay que recordar
una cosa es que Venezuela es el único
país de latinoamérica que tiene reservas
probadas de petróleo es el mayor no hay
ningún otro uno de los mayores en el
mundo como no vamos a querer tener unas
relaciones unas potentes relaciones
comerciales cuando estamos en medio de
una crisis planetaria en la que
necesitamos del petróleo la que
necesitamos del gas efectivamente
nuestro país no es un país petrolero es
un país con petróleo con petróleo
limitado no tenemos Ojalá tuvi las
reservas de Venezuela no tenemos el gas
que tiene Venezuela por lo tanto que
necesitamos por seguridad energética
sostener unas relaciones estables Más
allá de las posturas ideológicas porque
para otros asuntos si nos piden entonces
que no tengamos esas posturas
ideológicas pero para los asuntos
estratégicos en materia ambiental y en
materia energética en materia de
alimentación recuperar esos insumos para
la producción agrícola esos insumos a
buen precio es que los insumos
Internacionales no son un asunto
despreciable estamos dependiendo de la
volatilidad hoy de el peso colombiano de
la volatilidad Y de lo que está pasando
con nuestras finanzas al aumentarse el
dólar Entonces nosotros necesitamos
Fuentes más cercanas qué pasa con que
sean más cercanas precisamente que
dejamos una menor huella ecológica tener
relaciones comerciales con los más
cercanos es de suma importancia y quiero
referirme a lo de Perú que para mí es
muy importante que es un país que y
todos estamos en la obligación todos los
países del Mundo estamos en la
obligación de referirnos a las
violaciones a derechos humanos hoy lo
que está sucediendo en el Perú es un
crimen de lesa humanidad y todos y yo
celebro que mi presidente sea atreva a
pesar de los riesgos que eso implica a
pronunciarse en contra de ese crimen de
lesa humanidad de lo que está sucediendo
al pueblo peruano al pueblo indígena que
sale a la calle a protestar y a decir la
verdad de que keiko fujimori se atreva a
decirle a nuestro presidente yo sí tengo
que recordarle al mundo Quién es keiko
fujimori y así lo hice en mi cuenta de
Twitter Quién es cómo ha sido la hija de
una persona que en este momento se
tienen pruebas suficientes para decir
que tuvo incluso relaciones con este
país en términos armamentísticos en
términos del terrorismo transnacional
nosotros no podemos olvidar eso Entonces
decir no nos pronunciamos decir que no
decimos nada No yo creo que arriesgarse
en materia de Derechos Humanos a decir
en este país se respetaron las protestas
a ambos lados allá allá no se respeta
protestar dos reflexiones hablan de
relaciones armamentísticas o de
terrorismo y dicen no olvidar Yo respeto
mucho el presidente que tenemos pero la
historia del presidente que tenemos es
que perteneció a un grupo terrorista y
que ejerció actividades y acciones
terroristas contra los colombianos y
también hay fotos donde está con armas
fue un alzado en armas entonces
respetamos fue indultado todo ha
participado de la legalidad fue
congresista fue alcalde de Bogotá y hoy
es el presidente de la república Pero
como dice la senadora no podemos olvidar
tampoco lo podemos olvidar en Colombia y
lo segundo hablan de que tenemos que
tener buenas relaciones con Venezuela
por los por el petróleo pero imagínense
el grave problema que nosotros
dependiéramos del petróleo del gas de
Venezuela como lo está haciendo hoy
Europa que dependía del gas de Rusia y
hoy en los problemas que está cuando
podemos seguir explorando cuando podemos
seguir explotando petróleo y gas en
Colombia y lleguemos a importar gas ese
recibo que hoy tiene cualquier
colombiano se le tiene que multiplicar
por cinco veces de gas y en
hidrocarburos imagínense los efectos en
la tasa de cambio no recibir más
inversión en el sector de hidrocarburos
Mire lo que pasaría en la inflación el
momento que llegáramos a importar
hidrocarburos y los efectos en la
pobreza los efectos en nuestra economía
y hoy ya lo ha dicho la organización que
hoy existe en Colombia de hidrocarburos
del sector de hidrocarburos está
diciendo que podemos estar perdiendo
casi más o menos 100 billones de dólares
en inversión en Colombia por la actitud
del gobierno de cerrar esa industria
hidrocarburos con los impuestos que
crearon en una reforma tributaria el año
pasado más la voluntad de la ministra
que ha dicho que para que explorar y
explotar más porque lo dijo en davos en
Suiza claro justamente los trabajadores
del sector de hidrocarburos han
expresados y conformidad con la política
energética que ha expresado este este
gobierno en su intención Pues por
también empezar a hacer una transición
energética necesaria también a a todo
nivel Yo quiero añadirle senadora la uso
se ha pronunciado favor de la transición
energética
asociado y ha participado de todas las
actividades de los trabajadores de la
industria
petroleración y otra cosa son algunas
políticas o algunas reformas que quiero
hacer pero yo quiero Añadir Añadir acá
una cosa senadora que no me queda muy
clara y es esa necesidad que usted
estaba explicando de que Colombia
tuviera una posición frente a lo que
está ocurriendo en Perú estas
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos Pero
por qué ese mismo estándar no se aplica
por ejemplo a Nicaragua 222 personas
desterradas despojadas de su ciudadanía
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
constantes evidentes no lo digo yo lo
dicen las organizaciones internacionales
porque Colombia no tiene la posición
Clara frente a eso bueno lo primero hay
que recordar que para agradecer la
intervención del senador Ciro es
nosotros Hoy somos ciudadanos
planetarios todos en el planeta
dependemos de Quien tenga Fuentes
seguras de energía todos no hay ningún
país de este planeta que pueda aislarse
los han querido aislar en esa lógica no
todos tenemos que tener buenas
relaciones con quien tenga fuentes de
energía fijas las otras son volubles
vulnerables a la crisis climática es
decir si hay una prioridad en el mundo
precisamente por lo que está pasando en
Europa y me parece importante decirlo
porque porque nos han dicho que nos
aislemos en algunas materias no la
crisis planetaria Es crisis planetaria y
no tiene fronteras no hay manera de que
nosotros estemos aislados Y eso qué
quiere decir que hoy el mundo se
configurando en relación a los tipos de
energía y ese sí que es un debate
importante para nosotros Entonces esa
relación sí es potente es necesaria y no
se va a graduar porque exploremos o no
exploremos también el planeta está
diciendo hay que hacer la transición y
otros países están diciendo hay que
hacer la transición cuánto nos queda
para ello que es la duda qué tiempo nos
queda y Cómo podemos resolverlo no las
reservas que hoy tenemos que son también
fruto de una gran discusión de si
tenemos los elementos necesarios para
decir hoy son estas reservas nos van a
durar tantos años y eso pasa en
cualquier país del mundo la discusión no
es solo aquí la discusión es en todos
los países porque es un asunto
estratégico y de seguridad nacional es
decir hoy es tan importante la energía
como los asuntos de los ejércitos por
eso Esas relaciones crucial Yo sí
Considero que es crucial porque vamos a
depender de ella nosotros no tenemos
manera de tener certeza de cuánto dura
nuestra reserva así como muchos países y
en relación a la posición en materia de
Derechos Humanos
nosotros como Defensores de Derechos
Humanos siempre lo hemos hecho Nosotros
hemos tenido relaciones claras Porque
aquí se busca digamos esta posición de
la relación con Perú y de la relación
con Venezuela pero también tenemos una
relación con Brasil con el nuevo
presidente de Brasil una de las grandes
potencias el país más importante en
nuestra región Y esa relación es potente
y también es en perspectiva de Derechos
Humanos Qué pasaba con el anterior Qué
pasaba con el anterior no tiene presos
políticos
En el anterior Qué pasaba con el
anterior
gobernador de Brasil Nosotros sí lo
denunciamos quién estuvo de presidente Y
qué le hizo a la amazonía a la amazonía
que es el pulmón del mundo y sí hay que
pronunciarse sobre todas las violaciones
de derechos humanos y lo hemos dicho una
a una estén de nuestro lado o estén en
un lado ideológico contrario entiendo
pero no me responde el caso de Nicaragua
puntualmente adelante yo lo que digo es
hablan de transición energética en ya
comenzó el anterior presidente de
Colombia Iván Duque multiplicó en cuatro
años por 100 veces la capacidad
generación de energías limpias 2018 a
2022 entonces la transición energética
no es que la vaya a comenzar el
presidente Petro ya comenzó hace mucho
tiempo pero no por eso se debe abandonar
la posibilidad de no depender de otro
país sea Venezuela o sea el que sea si
tenemos la capacidad de tener nuestras
propias reservas Por qué depender de un
país que hoy es una dictadura alguien no
me puede decir que no es una dictadura
Es un régimen dictatorial que ha habido
violaciones de Derechos Humanos Entonces
eso es lo primero si nosotros tenemos la
capacidad porque depender de Venezuela y
quiero poner el caso de Europa con Rusia
si mañana se levanta con el pie
izquierdo el presidente determinado país
y no nos quiere seguir suministrando gas
O hidrocarburos Pues nosotros quedamos
en el peor de los mundos en materia
social económica y política a lo que yo
voy es si tenemos la capacidad nosotros
Porque la quieren cerrar y la quieren
cerrar porque la ministra de minas lo
que le gustaría porque no importar gas
de de Venezuela entonces Imagínese el
grave problema que nosotros podemos
tener en materia de poner en riesgo
nuestra seguridad energética en Colombia
y lo que quiero terminar diciendo es hoy
Colombia es uno de los líderes en los
últimos cuatro años en materia de
transición energética después de Chile
Colombia es de los primeros países en
multiplicar su capacidad de producir en
energías limpias en Latinoamérica no la
discusión sobre energías limpias es otra
cosa pero entonces estamos dependiendo
del tema ambiental que ya lo hemos
tocado bueno
por eso pero estamos pensando en el
largo plazo porque si no no hablaríamos
de exploración
porque están cerrando el Grifo sí le
respondí su pregunta disculpeme porque
el presidente Gustavo Petro se pronunció
solo ayer sobre los 94 las 94 personas
todas las violaciones de Derechos
Humanos absolutamente todas que no nos
podamos dedicar a pronunciarnos sobre
cada una de ellas faltaba más en México
nos hemos pronunciado nosotros como
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
firmemente contra las violaciones hacia
las mujeres contra los derechos de las
mujeres que es un crimen terriblemente
difícil pronunciarse porque luego pasa
Como por ejemplo con Perú que tomaron
una posición se pronunciaron y en Perú
los declararon persona no grata tema
importante también de La coyuntura
Internacional en donde le están pasando
factura no solamente a Colombia sino
también a otros países de la región no
hay un bloque en común de la región de
América Latina con una posición frente a
la guerra en Ucrania la invasión de
Rusia al territorio del este de Ucrania
Colombia tampoco tiene ningún tipo de de
posición allí es un conflicto muy
alejado pero hemos visto pero hemos
visto la repercusiones que tiene a nivel
económico para nosotros para la región
de América Latina aquí la posición de
Colombia que apostar a dónde ir ha
habido voces desde América Latina al
diálogo que es tal vez lo que uno no ve
desde Europa y desde Estados Unidos
Tuvimos una posición en contra de la
invasión de Rusia Ucrania presidente
Iván Duque el presidente anterior Tuvo
una oposición muy clara incluso envió
ayudas a Ucrania lo que pasa es que
cambia el gobierno Y hoy no sabemos Para
dónde va este gobierno en materia de
relaciones exteriores lo vimos con
Guatemala lo vemos con Perú que es
nuestra región y ahora con el caso de
Ucrania no ha tenido una posición seria
o concreta con respecto a esa invasión
de Rusia Ucrania y estamos a la espera
que la de por la repercusiones que eso
ha tenido en materia económica en
materias primas y muchas otras y yo creo
que sí es importante desde el congreso
lo hemos venido repitiendo incluso hemos
solicitado al canciller que Cuál es la
relación que hoy se tiene o cuál es el
pronunciamiento y la posición de
Colombia con respecto a esa situación
que hoy se está viviendo entre Rusia y
Ucrania por este lado senadora Bueno yo
creo que nuestras relaciones son muy
positivas de verdad la postura del
gobierno anterior en términos de
relaciones internacionales
para nosotros más que frustrante por lo
menos en el relacionamiento con Canadá
en el relacionamiento con hermanos
países de nuestra América los más
importantes y reitero Brasil Argentina
chile México que hace unas potencias en
materia de
posibilidades de que su economía sea
mejor detener mejores posibilidades
económicas y que nos den ejemplo también
en nuestra América Entonces yo creo que
el relacionamiento con los países
latinoamericanos ha mejorado el
relacionamiento con otros países también
yo creo que eso mismo que se le pide al
presidente Se le pide Entonces no hacer
observaciones sobre lo que pasa en Perú
si se nos pide para otras naciones y
otros continentes yo creo que ahí hay
que tener mucho cuidado y no se nos
puede olvidar quienes han sido los
grandes beneficiados de esa intervención
Y de esa guerra que se está sufriendo
hoy en Europa y Esos grandes
beneficiados también de los que hoy
dependemos porque se habla de una
autonomía en que no sabemos cuánto nos
va a durar y por eso las relaciones
internacionales son tan delicadas Cuando
somos un país dependiente somos hoy un
país dependiente en materia de alimentos
sí quién es el gran beneficiario de esa
guerra que se está dando el gran
beneficiario es una empresa de Estados
Unidos una empresa de Estados Unidos y
nosotros tenemos dependencia por
supuesto tenemos dependencia esas
relaciones son sumamente cuidadosas yo
creo que se está haciendo una tarea de
filigrana una tarea de filigrana de
saber de quién dependemos Cómo
dependemos y no estamos en la película
de que somos autónomos no somos
autónomos dependemos un montón en muchos
factores Y si tenemos algunas autonomías
son reducidas y están acotadas en el
tiempo me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa quedan muchos
temas sobre la mesa para debatir
Necesito que hagamos las conclusiones
para el cierre de lo que puede venir
para Colombia para los próximos meses o
tal vez para el próximo año para hacer
luego un balance de ese primer año de el
presidente Petro al mando de Colombia
hacia donde se dirige el país en en este
momento estamos en una coyuntura de
manifestaciones ciudadanas de protestas
salen también los taxistas en los
próximos días a manifestarse en contra
algunas de las políticas y porque
tampoco hay una posición definida frente
Por ejemplo a las plataformas digitales
de transporte que lo llevan aplazando ya
diferentes gobiernos Y hay muchos temas
sobre la mesa pero hacia el futuro hacia
los próximos meses comienzo con la
senadora qué proyección se puede hacer
qué rumbo vamos a tomar como país bueno
no yo creo que las manifestaciones
bienvenidas a mí me parece que llevar
ese debate a la calle independiente de
lo que eso puede generar a veces
incomodidades para la gente pero también
abusos de poder que se han presentado o
extralimitación de los mismos
manifestantes que deben saber que
nuestro marco constitucional es la
protesta pacífica a mí me parece eso muy
positivo tener una ciudadanía movilizada
tener una ciudadanía Ojalá sin feidos
Ojalá sin mentiras Ojalá sin
exacerbación realmente de lo que está
sucediendo porque vimos en las protestas
que realmente estaban diciendo cosas que
no eran ciertas que el presidente
Gustavo Petro había prohibido la fe
católica eso jamás ha pasado Nosotros
somos súper respetuosos y así lo hemos
dicho en el congreso súper respetuosos
de las distintas creencias entonces
Hacia dónde vamos efectivamente se van a
seguir expresando esas movilizaciones
ciudadanas maravillosos los debates van
a ser al interior del Congreso y afuera
y qué bueno que así sea por este lado
para hablarles a los colombianos en
todos los países vamos hacia el Abismo
una gran incertidumbre en materia
económica un presidente hablando desde
el balcón hace muy pocas noches del
palacio nariño es la casa presidencial
hablando como un activista de izquierda
como un opositor y no como el presidente
de todos los colombianos vemos un año
con una proyección económica negativa
por el Banco Central de Colombia
nosotros vemos una gran cantidad de
reformas que lo que quieren es estatizar
vamos hacia al Abismo y hay que
recordarle al presidente de la república
de Colombia que hoy es el presidente ya
no es el activi que lo fue durante
muchos años y que tiene que generar
confianza para este país y para todos
los colombianos senadores pues les
agradezco mucho por este análisis
habernos puesto en perspectiva de lo que
está sucediendo en este país
suramericano viendo como ha evolucionado
estos seis meses de gobierno del
presidente Petro Muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
estudio de France 24 es todo por hoy En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos la sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera Muchas
gracias Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales Siguen con nosotros
[Música]